the ocean
floor is littered with our engineering
failures and mistakes
you need to respect the power of what
happens out there
there's still things to be discovered if
we have a zero risk
philosophy we are doomed
when we first conceived this idea i
wasn't sure it was going to be possible
we were talking about an intelligent
vehicle out in the middle of the
atlantic ocean
we built a ship put autonomy into it and
now we're learning what that means
do you just maintain your course
[Music]
the pressure's certainly building as
we're getting closer to the launch
there's a lot that we
need to deliver
right right something going wrong
what keeps me up at night is we break
down somewhere in the middle of the
atlantic
and it's something so trivial
working on a boat like this you kind of
have to figure stuff out on your own
no no we need to find out what happened
but it wasn't responding
we'd lost cons i just want to finish
shaking her out and start across the
crossing the crossing the crossing
so when you say the crossing atlantic
that little thing
yeah yeah good luck
[Music]
when it pulls out of plymouth and i know
it's not coming back for six months
when i see the rear end of it and the
sternum are going around rain head
headed off west
that's going to be exciting ibm really
likes projects that are really pushing
the envelope to do really exciting and
novel things
what if we had hundreds of these vessels
this is going to transform ocean science
trying and failing doesn't bother me
it's if we don't do everything we can do
to ensure success
[Music]
you